we are one step closer to a subpoena of
the President of the United States we've
known for a while that special
prosecutor Robert Muller in the Trump
Russia investigation wants to speak to
Donald Trump we've known for a while
that most of the constantly rotating
cast of Donald Trump's personal
attorneys don't want Trump to have a
personal meeting with Robert Muller her
molars investigators and the reasons why
are obvious Trump is a megalomaniac and
a compulsive liar putting someone like
him in a room with skilled knowledgeable
investigators is not likely to end well
for Donald Trump so the idea we knew was
being floated was well maybe they'll do
a written interview or in other words
Muller will send a list of questions to
Trump's lawyers who would then write
answers on behalf of Donald Trump and
this would be not a great way to conduct
an investigation it would allow Trump to
leave out relevant information that
would come up in a conversation it would
allow Trump's lawyers to really sort of
sanitize what Trump has done said or new
to the most utterly benign statements
such that they will be effectively
meaningless to robert muller in his
investigation well the good news is
we've now learned that Robert Mulder
says no we're not doing a written
interview and this is the correct
decision this is the obvious decision
the mere premise that Trump should be
allowed in an investigation of this
magnitude and at this level of this
caliber to have his lawyers write down
answers is completely asinine it is not
how a good criminal investigation is
done period he can show up and plead the
fifth if he wants sure which by the way
Trump says if he plead the fifth that
means you're guilty or if he gets
subpoenaed he can try to figure out a
way around the subpoena but lawyers
writing answers for you give me a break
this is not a take-home midterm in
sociology 101 right show up and do what
you're supposed to do and I will warn
you the reason we know that the offer
for a written interview has been
rejected is because Trump's newest
lawyer Rudy Giuliani told CBS News about
this Rudy has had a very fast and loose
relationship with the truth over the
last few days and these disastrous
interviews and statements he's been
doing so it's always possible that we
just can't believe Rudy but no one's
contra
this so there's every indication that
yeah Moeller has said no no no we're not
going to just do a written interview
there are now two directions that this
could go right Trump agrees to an
in-person interview or Trump does not
agree to an in-person interview and at
that point Robert Muller will also have
a choice to make if Trump does not agree
to the in-person interview does robert
muller issue a subpoena or does he say
you know what i'm not going to issue the
subpoena and if robert muller does issue
the subpoena then we will have a
situation where it may get up to the
Supreme Court to adjudicate whether
Donald Trump as a sitting president is
bound by the power of Robert Muller's
subpoena I don't know the answer
numerous legal scholars say that a
sitting president would have to comply
with a subpoena from Robert Muller there
are others particularly those in the
Trump camp who say that may not be the
case and he's not going down without a
fight so it could get very very ugly I
think it's certainly a no-win situation
for Trump if he takes the interview he's
probably going to lie to the FBI and
that's a serious charge or tell the
truth and admit to really bad things
because he doesn't even know or bad
that's possible - or if it goes to the
courts I think it's likely going to be
decided that the president can be
subpoenaed and maybe they'll rule on
more things - like can the president be
indicted and I don't think that's a road
he wants to go down I don't know I mean
that's interesting I don't know that
they would actually be in a position to
rule as to whether the president can be
indicted until there's an attempt at an
indictment same reason why they're not
ruling on the subpoena power now they
would need an actual case to be appealed
there but those are the types of
questions that are very very quickly
going to become key issues this could
end up at the Supreme Court where
Trump's buddy Neil Gorsuch would have a
role in deciding whether the subpoena
power stands or not from Robert Moeller
as far as timing Giuliani is saying he
needs a few weeks to get up to speed on
everything going on I think that the
recent interviews prove that Rudy
Giuliani isn't quite up to speed yet and
they also want to wait beyond the North
Korea summit hilarious explanation
though right like does anyone imagine
that the guy who so put the other
element to this that I want to mention
is that Giuliani says Trump needs time
to prepare for the North Korea summit so
he they can't deal with this right now
Trump demands all materials be on one
page and be mostly pictures like does
anyone believe he's intensely preparing
for the North Korea summit oh and he has
time to tweet all day but somehow it
doesn't have time for the actual
activities of being president doesn't
make any sense whatsoever and it's
really really important in these
situations to zoom out a little bit
sometimes we get lost in the details the
circumstances are that the legal team
for the President of the United States
does not want the president to be
interviewed because either they're
worried he will lie or they're worried
that he will tell the truth a truth that
will get him in even more trouble and
that's the ultimate underlying reality
remember that Hillary Clinton testified
for hours on television and Trump's
lawyers don't want him sitting down at
all even behind closed doors with Robert
Muller or his investigators and this is
why there are rumors in Washington once
again about the attempt or desire to
fire Robert Muller and we're going to
talk about that a little bit later on in
the program the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad